the headline says not even cnn buys the
claim that abortion is the most
important issue for voters this was an
interesting exchange between that's a
cnn host on the left cnn hosts victor
blackwell and that's democratic
representative judy chu of california
now her claim we don't even need to play
the video it's not important to play the
video we can you know talk about it but
her claim was that essentially what's
going on with the supreme court and
what's going on with abortion
that's a motivating issue for voters
that's going to be what voters turn out
to uh to you know vote they're gonna
vote based on that like all women's
rights all this stuff well it was
interesting because typically you would
expect a cnn host to agree
well victor blackwell had something
different to say he comes back and he he
brings in a poll
and he says as democrats say this issue
should motivate voters is a new york
times siena college poll that asked
about the most important issues for
voters it's still the economy inflation
in fact for democrats and independents
abortion rights
doesn't surpass inflation you don't say
she comes back in and she's like well
i've never seen such anger outrage and
terror among women in this country
everywhere i go
he comes back again he wasn't letting he
was like again the polls show that the
economy inflation and other items i just
read are what's really motivating voters
so here's the thing right
we talk about
this woman is living in a bubble we just
talked about a bubble
with the little you know social she's in
a bubble she's in a bubble where she's
talking about women rights and abortion
all day long and maybe she's in a
privileged position i don't know maybe
she's in a privileged position where
you know the price of gasoline inflation
the price of regular goods that you go
to the grocery store and buy food um
whether or not you have a job isn't
playing a role in her decision making
right now that's a privileged position
to be in republican democrat i don't
care it's a privileged position
what she's lost touch with is the
reality that there are tiers
of issues that people care about when
they go to vote right the first tier is
always jobs in the economy do you have
one is the economy ripe to help you get
one
along with that is inflation because
inflation affects the price of goods and
services so if you can't put food on the
table if you can't fill your car up with
gas to get from point a to point b
you're not talking about abortion and
climate change you can't get there right
it can't be a priority for you if you
can't put food on the table nothing else
matters you can't feed your family
nothing else matters nothing else
matters except maybe your health
maybe your health is up there too and by
the way those things become huge sources
of stress and affect people's health
tier two
is what happens when you have the
privilege privilege to say i don't need
to worry about my finances i don't need
to worry about whether or not i have a
job because i have one i don't need to
worry about gas prices because i can
afford those things those people can
then go talk about climate change
abortion and whatnot
so in this election and all the polling
is showing it economy inflation these
things are going to be number one this
woman is living in a bubble
there's some other things that i think
are going to be number one too we talk
about crime here a lot
it's affecting the cities around the
country people are worried about that
and a lot of people are starting to wake
up i think and say a lot of these woke
policies in these cities this isn't
going so well if you can't walk out your
front door and go to the grocery store
and walk there in peace without worrying
about your safety that becomes a
priority issue think about it like the
core
of what people care about whether or not
you can food on the table the safety of
your of yourself and your family your
basic needs
not stuff that feels removed from you a
little bit right
these are your tier one issues
also i think what's going to be really
interesting this election
you heard it here for maybe not first
but you heard it here is the parent vote
i'm really curious to see the reaction
of parents who are looking at what's
going around going on around the country
and how all of this
stuff that's happening in schools and
how all of the mandates that are
affecting their kids and the mass
mandates and the vaccine and all that
stuff and all the curriculum stuff we're
seeing from you know we put those videos
up from lives of tick tock all the time
talking about like you know the drag
shows at the schools and how how much do
parents really care about that stuff i
think the parent vote is going to be key
this time around as well
but again you can't put food on the
table you're not worried about anything
else you got to eat right your family's
got to eat that's number one
okay so it's sad but these congressmen
and women sometimes i mean the bubble
they're in is just i don't know that's
some sturdy [ __ ] that they're living in
they talk to their oh
i went to a lunch and i spoke to other
congresswomen and they also did you get
out into the communities did you talk to
me because i'm not hearing that when i
talk to women the concerns i have are
about jobs and about economy before i
ever hear about abortion i hear about
whether or not they can feed themselves
their families and how well off i i hear
about their 401k shrinking
i hear about fears about money
take over
they take over right for everybody if
you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here